end of the day I think where we're going
is something I call the thank you
economy I believe firmly that we are
living through the humanization of
business the reason that so many people
watch my show buy my books why I am one
of the top 300 followed people on
Twitter and by far the least famous or
brand recognized is because
I out cared everybody if you can figure
out how to first care about the people
in your world and your organization
because the only thing more important in
the customer are your employees and your
teammates care about them trickle that
down into the trenches recognize that
the consumer's [ __ ] radar is greater
than ever and recognize that the
attention of that consumer is Shifting
in front of our eyes figure out how to
natively talk there and actually give a
crap for the first time not just your
bottom line but go for a long play
instead of short-term good feelings and
I promise you you have a much better
chance of succeeding in the thank you
economy